shall we start by talking about height
of these objects and why that's really
key yes good morning yes this is the
fourth sort of incident in the last week
the first one which was the Chinese uh
balloon with as you can just see below
it the payload underneath it so exactly
what it was doing there this was above
60 000 feet
um why is that important is that the
that's well clear of any airlines it's
well clear of most military traffic and
therefore uh it doesn't pose a risk to
anything flying it's more a question of
what was it doing there and what how is
it doing there the other instance though
the one on Saturday the the incident
that was at forty thousand feet and
that's at the top end of where the
airlines operate and is heart of the
envelope for where military jets operate
and then if you look at the Sunday shoot
down around and Canada that was
allegedly around 20 000 feet and that's
right in The Sweet Spot of where all the
civilian traffic operate and uh that if
you you can just imagine hundreds of
people inside an airline that is you do
not want to be hitting stuff there and
that's therefore it poses a real flight
safety risk now the first one and as I
said because of the we don't know the
payload exactly here and the other ones
are probably just objects as we know at
the moment but it's worth noting as
Justin Bronx said um there are so many
satellites in orbit these days that are
looking for uh track the weather and
it's much easier to track it up there
it's very hard to believe that people
would be putting weather tracking
capability into a balloon these days
indeed indeed let's talk about the
technology issue because this is also
key because any technology comes with a
big price tag it does and for a military
perspective it's fascinating because
um actually tracking balloons is quite
difficult to do a conventional radar
sends out a ping and needs to bounce off
something so that's why you have stealth
aircraft with lots of careful
um Corners no sharp edges lots of
specific coverings and they're all
designed specifically to avoid radar
detection whereas balloons are really
difficult to detect particularly when
they're very high and they're a long way
away
um so the America almost certainly we
will have technology to track this sort
of stuff the challenge is they won't
always want to tell the world how good
their Radars are and of course as soon
as you say you're able to track
something that's that big then your
enemy will try to create something
that's that big so there's a lot of
Tolerance apply we've heard literally
the other day the Americans have dialed
up the sensitivity of the um of their
Radars you think uh yeah okay is that
political language that you know we we
can see this stuff but we now our
patients has run to a limit in terms of
the cost these aircraft the f-22s these
are you know 200 million dollar
airplanes the missile that was used to
shoot the last one down am9x missile
that's about four hundred thousand
dollars of of missiles so and almost
certainly the target wasn't worth
anything like that but but this is
actually more about the politics there's
a clear statement of intent here this is
about political on both sides and also
it's worth pointing out actually
operating over enemy territory between
spying is nothing new you too Gary
Powers operating over the urals were
shot down
um so and that was before the days
really where we had lots of satellites
but both sides both China Russia the
America the Brits all look using
satellite technology and observe over
each other's territory the challenges
these days it's highly unlikely that
you'd need to do that with balloons so
from a military perspective the bigger
worry is actually what you're doing is
testing your America's defenses how
would they operate how could they shoot
down something like this because a
little balloon is cheap as chips to
produce therefore if you put 10 100 a
thousand ten thousand in so what the the
worry from the West will be what the
implications of this but undoubtedly
it's all heightening political tensions
at a time when you're never quite sure
which party is actually this suits which
country to do that indeed I'm sure we'll
be covering this for days maybe weeks to
come Sean always a pleasure thank you so
much